Usa la fórmula cuadrática
para resolver la ecuación
"-x" cuadrada más 8x igual a 1,
y bueno, lo que dice la fórmula cuadrática
es que las ecuaciones de la forma
"ax" cuadrada más "bx" más "c",
esto igualado a 0,
tienen como solución "x" igual a "-b"
más menos la raíz cuadrada,
de "b" cuadrada menos 4 veces "a" por "c",
todo esto está dentro de la raíz cuadrada
y esto dividido entre 2 veces "a",
todo esto dividido entre 2 veces "a"
y bueno,
esta es una fórmula muy importante,
que algún día te debes de aprender por que la vamos a ocupar bastante cuando veamos matemáticas.
Ahora lo que quiero que veas es que aquí tenemos la ecuación en su posición estándar,
porque está igualada a 0
y tenemos los términos de "x" ordenados
de exponente mayor a exponente menor,
y si te das cuenta el problema aquí
es que no lo tenemos igualado a 0,
y entonces para ponerla en su forma estándar,
lo que voy a hacer es restar -1,
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
-1 de este lado y -1 también de este lado,
entonces,
¿qué voy a obtener?
"-x" cuadrada
después más 8x
y después -1.
Aquí nada se puede simplificar,
y del otro lado
¿Qué me queda?
-1 más 1 se va.
Esto me da 0 y bueno,
entonces ahora si ya lo tengo en la forma estándar,
si te das cuenta
tengo ya igualado a 0 esta ecuación cuadrática,
y además tengo primero
lo que tiene que ver
con "x" cuadrada, después lo que tiene que ver con "x", después lo que tiene que ver con  la constante,
y esto igualado a 0,
entonces aquí ya puedo saber varias cosas,
ya puedo decir que "a" vale
-1,
"a" vale -1
porque es
el coeficiente que está al lado de la "x" cuadrada,
si te das cuenta aquí tenemos "-x" cuadrada,
"-x" cuadrada
pues es lo mismo que tener
-1x cuadrada,
recuerda que cuando tenemos
"-x" cuadrada es lo mismo
que tener -1 por "x" cuadrada,
porque la multiplicación por 1 es lo mismo,
y entonces me queda que "a" vale -1,
éste de aquí.
¡Perfecto! Y después yo tengo
más bx
y aquí entonces me dice que "b"
vale 8,
es este 8 que tengo aquí,
este de aquí es lo que vale "b",
y depués para finalizar
a esto le tengo que sumar "c"
más "c" pero,
¿cuánto vale "c" en esta ocasión?
"c" vale -1 con todo el signo,
es muy importante tomar
todos estos valores
con todo y signo
"c" era el valor
de la constante que vale -1,
entonces ahora sí, ya que tengo el valor de
"a", "b" y "c",
voy a aplicar la fórmula cuadrática,
para saber cuáles son las raíces
de esta ecuación cuadrática.
Entonces,
¿qué voy a obtener?
Vamos a cambiar "x" es igual,
¿a quién?
a "-b"
pero "b" vale 8,
entonces déjame ponerlo con el color de "b"
-8 más menos,
más menos,
vamos a hacerlo con mucho cuidado,
la raíz cuadrada
de "b" cuadrada pero "b" vale 8,
entonces es la raíz cuadrada
de 8 elevado al cuadrado,
y a esto le tengo que quitar
menos 4 veces ac,
menos 4 veces "a" que vale -1,
entonces vámonos al color de "a",
esto por -1 por "c"
pero "c" vale también -1 entonces,
a esto hay multiplicarlo también por - 1
y a todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre 2 veces "a"
entonces 2 que multiplica a -1
2 por -1 y bueno,
esto
¿a quién es igual?
Vamos a hacerlo, esto es lo mismo,
¿qué quién?
Tengo "x" es igual a -8
es este 8 de aquí,
más menos la raíz cuadrada
¿De quién?
De 8 al cuadrado lo cual es 64
-4 por "a" por "c",
menos por menos me da más,
por menos me da menos, vamos bien aquí
4 por 1 por 1,
me da 4,
y a todo esto lo tengo que dividir entre 2 por -1,
lo cual me da -2
y esto por cierto, ¿a cuánto es igual?
a -8
más menos la raíz cuadrada
¿de quién?
voy a simplificar lo que está aquí adentro
64 - 4 me da 60,
y a todo esto lo tengo que dividir entre -2.
¡Perfecto!
Pero aquí el problema
es que 60 no tiene raíz cuadrada exacta,
por lo tanto lo que se me ocurre es que podemos simplificar un poco esta raíz,
factorizando al número 60
¿qué me quedaría?
60, 60 a su vez tiene mitad
y la mitad de 60 es 30
30, 30 a su vez tiene mitad
y la mitad de 30 es 15
15, 15 a su vez tiene tercera,
la tercera de 15 es 5.
Date cuenta que 15 ya no tiene mitad,
por eso saque tercera,
y bueno 5 ya no tiene mitad,
ya no tiene tercera
lo único quetiene es quinta,
por lo tanto podemos escribir
la raíz de 60
de esta forma,
como la raíz de 2 por 2 por 3 por 5,
¿Y esto quién es?
Pues esto es lo mismo,
que tomarme la raíz de 2 por 2
y después tomarme la raíz
de 3 por 5,
porque la raíz cumple esta propiedad
que se puede dividir cuando los que están adentro
están multiplicándose,
y eso es igual a la raíz de 2 por 2,
que es la raíz de 4, lo cual es 2,
y ahí después tengo
la raíz de 3 por 5,
en lo cual no se puede simplificar,
y entonces lo voy a poner como la raíz de 15
y bueno, entonces esto me da pie
a que esta expresión de aquí
la pueda poner de la siguiente manera,
esto es lo mismo que tener -8
más menos la raíz cuadrada
¿de quién?
De 60 pero 60 es lo mismo que
2 veces la raíz de 15.
Entonces más menos
2 veces la raíz de 15
y todo esto dividido entre -2,
y aquí ya tengo mis 2 posibles resultados
si me tomo esta expresión con signo positivo,
y esta expresión con signo negativo.
Pero bueno nos hemos quedado sin espacio,
así que para obtener la respuesta correcta,
déjenme mover un poco esta pantalla,
para que yo pueda ser un poco más de espacio
y entonces
así terminar este problema.
¿Qué me va a quedar?
"x" es igual ¿a quién?
a -8
más menos 2 veces
la raíz cuadrada de 15
entre -2,
y bueno, pues esto me da pie
a pensar en mis 2 soluciones,
mi primera solución
nueva queda de la siguiente manera,
"x" es igual a -8
más, me voy a tomar el primer signo,
que es el signo positivo,
2 veces la raíz de 15
esto entre -2.
Éste es mi primer solución,
si me tomo el primer signo, el signo positivo
y por otra parte, tengo que "x"
es igual a -8,
menos 2 veces la raíz de 15,
todo esto dividido entre -2,
aquí tengo mi otra raíz
porque tiene ya el signo negativo
y entonces estoy separando estos 2 signos en una primera raíz, con el signo positivo
y en la segunda raíz  con signo negativo,
pero ¿qué crees?
Date cuenta que esto que tenemos aquí,
es lo mismo
¿Qué quién?
Voy a dividir éste entre éste,
y qué me va a quedar,
me queda -8 entre -2
lo cual me da 4 positivo,
menos entre menos me da más,
8 entre 2 me da 4
y después tengo esto de acá,
que es
más entre menos me da menos,
2 entre 2, se va
y solamente me queda la raíz de 15,
raíz de 15.
Esta es mi primera solución,
mi primera raíz,
y por otro lado tengo esta expresión que tengo aquí,
¿y qué me queda?
pues voy a hacer lo mismo,
voy a dividir primero estos 2
y tengo menos entre menos me da más,
8 entre 2, me da 4
y por otra parte tengo estos dos,
y estos dos qué me quedan,
-2 y -2 se cancelan,
y solamente me queda
más la raíz de 15,
y aquí está, ya lo hemos logrado.
Tengo aquí mis 2 raíces
de ésta ecuación cuadrática,
que fue con la que empecé,
que está aquí arriba.
Y entonces ya sé que si yo pongo,
estas 2 raíces que acabo de encontrar,
en esta ecuación,
entonces voy a encontrar,
que éstas dos,
son la solución de esta ecuación cuadrática.